speak of the house Kevin McCarthy
responded to the hunter Biden
uh plea agreement and we talked about
this on yesterday's show Hunter Biden is
expected to plead guilty to two
misdemeanor charges in relation to not
paying his taxes
um he since has paid them back but not
paying them for a time there and then he
will get one felony gun related charge
dismissed he lied on a form saying he
wasn't addicted to a control substance
to get a gun when he was and that will
be dismissed if he follows through
certain guidelines and the narrative
from the right as we talked about
yesterday has been sweetheart deal this
is a sweetheart deal and we're kind of
wrapping up the week so I'm going back
to some clips I didn't have a chance to
talk about this being one of them just
because of the dishonesty that is
gushing out of Kevin McCarthy it's
notable that this is how dishonest so
many people have to be to cover for
Trump and their narrative that uh
there's this two-tier justice system
hurting people like Trump so here's the
first clip we'll look at it
show
the two-tier system in America if you
are the president's leading political
opponent doj tries to literally put you
in jail and give you present time if you
are the president's son you get a
sweetheart now this does nothing to our
investigation it actually should enhance
our investigations because the doj
should not be able to withhold any
information now saying that because a
pending investigation they should be
able to provide chairman Comer with any
information that he requires so you
heard him say
the fact that the doj would try to put
the political opponent of the president
in jail while giving a sweetheart deal
to Hunter Biden
proves the two-tier justice system
talking point we've been perpetuating
which we'll talk about Trump but I'll
show this clip I think I showed this uh
one yesterday once again to remind you
that that talking point of sweetheart
deal is not accurate then we'll Circle
back to the Trump component obviously
you're already hearing a lot of shouting
oh sweetheart deal oh this oh that none
of us really knows the details of the
possible charges here and exactly what
was agreed to as part of this plea
Jennifer but how do how does one assess
whether this is the type of deal that a
normal person not a President's child
would get in this circumstance so you
would look to other similar cases right
so on the gun form charge it's very very
standard for someone in this situation
who lies on the form because they're an
addict the gun is long gone apparently
only had it for a couple of weeks it's
very standard in these circumstances for
this diversion to occur and to wipe out
the charges assuming he successfully
completes it so that's totally standard
and the tax fraud is is similar as well
I mean he paid those taxes back a long
time ago that's something that doj takes
very very seriously when okay and when
you look at historical precedent when
you look at other cases like this one
it's not some sweetheart deal
um but then he mentioned Trump and this
is a narrative then we have one more
clip to get two of Captain McCarthy with
money Raju
um but it's a narrative that is so
present right now so annoying oh the
doj's trying to lock up the political
opponent of Biden
what that tries to do is to take the
conversation away from
what Trump is being accused of because
if there was nothing substantive to what
Trump was being accused of then you
could have a conversation about why are
these charges being brought then but the
indictment is extensive in the evidence
it brings forward so then what is so
enraging is that uh individuals like Kim
McCarthy refuse to just completely
engage with the evidence engage with the
accusations because if they were to do
that then the conversation is no longer
Hunter Biden got a sweetheart deal when
he didn't and Trump is getting locked up
which we'll see obviously the whole he
has his due process and everything but
if that ends up happening and Trump was
indicted see that shows inherently
there's something unfair they couldn't
do that because they would have to argue
then therefore
uh not enforcing the law is that Trump
is being accused of violating which they
would never say they would never
explicitly say no yeah I don't think we
should enforce the Espionage Act I don't
think we should enforce that
or I don't think we should protect
National Security Secrets they would
never want to say that so it just has to
be vaguely Trump's being indicted and
Hillary's not yeah well what are the
facts of the case
uh here's another moment Congress has to
have a right we have the constitutional
right to investigate and to oversee and
for any investigation that we have or
any information we need we can't now
stand behind that there's an
investigation going on but there's two
separate cases I mean the Trump cases
involving alleged obstruction of an
investigation alleged misstatements this
is a tax case and a gun case these are
two separate cases why conflate them I'm
not conflating them but they're
allegedly lied to investigators that's
that's the issue handle it different
well did
did Hunter Biden lie about his taxes
that Hunter Biden lie about the gun well
I don't know he pleaded guilty to the
situation
well there's no there's no time for him
to serve remember this will be no prison
time but they're trying to put president
Trump in prison that's what they're
different cases they're different facts
about equal
Equal justice
what you talk about equal justice is
that what you think Equal justice is
Kevin McCarthy okay the universe says if
Trump is indicted then that means some
democrat somewhere has to be indicted
what
oh it's so unserious it is so
humiliating why why is that the
narrative and people have said this uh I
went as you all know to Miami to Trump's
arrest and arraignment in talk to
Trump's pores and one of them actually a
bunch of them but one of them kept
repeating well why hasn't Hillary been
indicted
that's not how it works because Hillary
didn't do the things or there wasn't
evidence for her doing the things that
Trump did
they didn't uncover the very Criminal
Intent that it seems they're uncovering
uncovering with Trump and they didn't
even ever get accused of the same things
why are so that's one level of absurdity
the Hillary or Biden conflation with
with Trump
a whole nother level of uh conflation is
saying that Hunter Biden should be
compared with Trump's case
Hunter bind was accused of evading his
taxes for two years and lying on a
Federal Form about a gun
Trump's accused of you know
keeping classified information he's not
supposed to have lying to Federal
authorities about having the classified
information
obstructing an investigation as they're
trying to get back to classified
information
um and on and on conspiring with other
individuals to keep out of the hands of
federal authorities he's classified
documents and that compares to Hunter
Biden Howe that's as absurd as
um
you're accused for any crime and you
start talking about someone's speeding
ticket that that should Justice should
be served there too but just very
different levels of Justice unless
they're saying that all the other cases
that have ended in very similar deals as
the hunter Biden one has should have led
to prison sentences which I don't think
they would say can you imagine if Trump
did the very things
um can you imagine if Trump went to
prison for evading his taxes
they would go
bonkers
I don't even know how that would work
but
um or he lied on a federal Forum about
getting a firearm and they put him in
prison
they would go Bonkers
um but dishonesty is inevitably going to
lead to a humiliating moment like that
one I guess we have much more on the
other side of this break
one of our sponsors today is fume not
everything in a bad habit is wrong so
instead of a drastic uncomfortable
change why not just remove the bad part
from your habit fume is an Innovative
award-winning device that does exactly
that fume is not electronic there's no
Vapor or harmful chemicals fume is just
a delicious flavored air that makes
replacing your bad habit easy your fume
comes with an adjustable airflow dial
and is designed with movable Parts which
is great for fidgeting which can be
great for people breaking bad habits
look at what people online are saying
they weren't sure what to expect but
ended up loving the taste and the feel
stopping is something lots of people put
off because it's difficult to do but
switching to fume is easy and enjoyable
there's no reason that you can't be the
next fume success story head on over to
try fumed dot com and use the code
Pacman to save 10 percent when you get
the journey pack which comes with the
device and three flavors the link is
down below